[Music]
[Applause]
future Hall of Famer three-time NFL
defensive player of the year now a
studio analyst for CBS Sports JJ Watt
joining us do you need any advice for
the job now that you're going to have at
CBS I'm sure you have great people
around you but uh if I can help you with
any advice you let me
know Dan I am no idiot I take all advice
from Legends of the game so please lay
it on me my friend okay when they ask
you a question as an analyst you hit
first so don't don't water down what
you're going to say so if I say how good
do you think the Jets are going to be
and then St Patrick's the best show on
TV thank you that's the right answer
that's the right answer but you need to
have your most important statement right
up top and then you fill in after it
okay ask me again ask me again uh what
are your expectations for the Jets this
year better than last
year I need a little bit longer yeah see
what I did there but I no but then you
fill it in they then you fill it in
after that okay better than last year
they added a good quarterback to their
team I'm kidding I'm kidding I do I
think the Jets are going to be
significantly better than last year I
mean are they a Super Bowl caliber
team now that is a legitimately great
question Dan um I don't know about that
I think that Aaron is reinvigorated I
think he's really really excited to be
there and he wants to prove that he's
great I think their defense is very very
strong um Super Bowl caliber that's just
it's another level it's a it's a very
very high bar and I there's a couple
teams that are just really tough to take
out in that Division I mean the Chiefs
are always going to be the favorites
until somebody proves otherwise so I
don't know about that level but
certainly playoff contenders when you
look at injuries you got Travis Kelce
with a hyperextended knee what is that
mean to you as far as his availability
having something like
that I mean the fact that it happened
yesterday uh and they play tomorrow
that's I mean I would imagine that would
be a tough one I mean I'm no doctor I'm
not gonna but I would imagine that's a
tough one that's that's a painful thing
even though it may not create any real
long-term damage in the short term is a
very painful injury and creates some
inflammation which makes it hard to do
what he has to do bigger loss Bosa or
Chris Jones for their respective
teams man that's a really good one I
mean I think that
overall better player like like just if
you're taking their whole game out of
the two I think I think Bosa but for
what he means to that team I would say
probably Chris Jones right now
especially um with the lions running
game like I I think this I saw Chris
Long talking about it yesterday a little
bit um with the lions running game and
what's what could happen on Thursday
night this could be a proving point for
him in his negotiations of saying like
hey this is what I bring that you guys
didn't have on Thursday night you know
and jir Gibbs is you know one of the
favorites for rookie of the year the
lions running back so that that might be
exposed a little bit is what you're
saying with Chris Jones and then with
Nick Bosa is Bosa the best Edge it okay
this might be tough for you to answer
who is who is the best Edge rusher in
football TJ watt okay I me it's there
there's no there's no debate there um
there are there's an incredible class of
edge rushers right now okay the best
best Edge rusher not related to you is
who to me that is a tie between Bosa and
Michel Parson um I think I think those
two are very good and I think Miles
Garrett is definitely in that
conversation as well I think there's an
there's an incredible Max Crosby I mean
the class right now is really good but
do I think Bosa deserves to be the
highest paid player in football right
now uh non-quarterback yes because
that's how the league works it's his
time he's up for a contract right now
and that's how this league works if
you're up you get the highest contract
and he deserves the highest contract
he's JJ watad he'll be part of CBS
Sports uh a studio analyst what are you
going to do on Sundays now like how do
you replicate or try to replicate that
feeling that you've had for a long long
time yeah you know I'm I've really kind
of become very comfortable with it um
there's no doubt there's going to be
times where I'm like gosh I wish I just
go out there and hit somebody I wish I
could just go out there and just lay you
know lay a nice sack um but I'm I'm
really looking forward to watching it
and I think even just preparing for this
season and watching film and talking to
players around the league I've been it's
been nice to be able to really have
conversations with guys from other teams
and talk in depth with other coaches
about you know schemes and things like
that whereas in the past I was a little
more closed up because you still have
that competitor in you where you don't
want to you know I don't want to give
away any secrets I don't I don't want
any like friendliness between the teams
because I we're competitors now I've
really enjoyed opening up and looking
around the league and seeing what
everybody does and uh it's going to be
fun obviously I'm doing uh some some
stuff for CBS this fall but I'm also
going to have some Sundays open where I
just sit on the couch and I watch the
games and uh I'm G to go up to
Pittsburgh and see TJ play and it's
going to be a lot of fun I know you were
uh tweeting about Colorado football with
what Dion did uh you got Travis Hunter
who is a two-way player I'm wondering
can you see that happening like you
played some tight end when you first
went to college and then you know became
an edge rusher but could you could you
do double duty in the
NFL you could definitely do it sparingly
you there's no way you could do it
full-time I mean he's an incredible
athlete what he did on Saturday is
incredible um we'll be fascinated to see
how they manage it throughout the season
I mean um he's incredible athlete he's
young he certainly can handle that
workload he proved it uh over the course
of a season it's very difficult I mean
he's what probably 21 years old so you
can do a lot more things when you're 21
than when you're 31 um but at the NFL
level with just the intensity with the
speed with the also the knowledge the
things that you have to study and know
um but if anybody's going to do it it's
GNA be somebody coached by Dion a guy
who did it a guy who understands the
rigors of it a guy who understands how
difficult it can be um but it is hard I
mean if you're going to do it full-time
I just think about the film study that
you have to do on one side of the ball
now you multiply it to the other side um
the practice reps that you need at each
to be to grow and to get better at each
um but man it would be fascinating I
mean what he did on Saturday was
incredible yeah who's the best athlete
that you
faced that maybe could have played
played two
ways that's a great question I mean
there's so many guys like
uh I'm trying to think of what position
because there there's different
positions obviously like there's a bunch
of offensive lineman um that I think
could if you train properly obviously
could play on a defensive line there's
some receivers that could certainly play
DB um it's always the old joke that
there's a reason the DBS don't play
receivers because they can't catch um
but it's
uh I mean I always thought that like
I feel like Grant could have rushed the
passer pretty well you know I think
Grant could Grant could have done that I
mean I'm trying to think there's got to
be a tight end like I feel like tight
ends are the position that really could
transition to the other side of the ball
like George KD I'm blanking
I'm yeah I think KD I mean I feel
like I'm completely blinking right now
the like these these quarterbacks
obviously can do mult things like I'm
thinking Jaylen Herz like Jaylen Herz is
an incredible athlete like he could do
so many different things out there he's
got to be able to and he had to played
multiple ways growing up by the way you
had myself oh you yeah you could have
played you could have played tight end
right I had you had three receptions I
think in college didn't you in the pr I
had I have I have three NFL touchdowns
on offense yeah okay yeah so you could
have played you could have been
grank um it's very tough the two-way
thing is is the truth we we literally
discussed it um as a possibility of you
know packages out in the field not just
the goal line but it it really is hard I
mean the the knowledge and the meetings
and everything you have to do it's it's
a difficult task you're uh tell me what
you're doing with the uh Youth Flag
Football clinic in Houston
today yeah my wife and I are doing some
a little flag football Clinic here in
Houston we obviously love Houston it's
an incredible place and um with Fredo Le
and with Cheetos we're doing in gen
youth we're doing a little flag football
clinic today
um and we're going to be there's going
to be some grab Ando meals that we're
putting into schools um for food
insecurity is a big issue uh in this
country unfortunately kids don't have
food um so Fredo and Cheetos me and Che
are doing some great work putting
grabbing go stations in schools and gen
youth is putting on these giving NFL
FLAG Football kids to school so kids can
participate in flag football and kind of
get introduced to the game and get out
there and be active so we're very
excited to partner with them and I'm
going back to the Texans facility today
for the first time in a few years and
I'm looking forward to that if you and
your wife ran a 40- yard
dash I would get smoked okay
unfortunately yeah um she's an
incredible athlete
then bench press I I still like
myself well okay what do you bench in
now um right now I mean I can I can
still put up 405 definitely um Bey that
how much 405
405 yeah one rep one rep 405 yeah I mean
not that I would um there's there's I'm
finding out more and more there's no
reason for me doing no
no it's a hard habit to break like I'm
I'm doing my workouts every day and I'm
I'm making them up myself and I'm
sitting there like planning it thinking
for what like like why why am I putting
this much weight on the bar for nobody's
impressed nobody cares like it doesn't
matter
your son's going to one day I hope so I
hope by doing it long enough where he
cares he watches me right now and I'm
hoping he like through osmosis he's like
I want to work out uh have fun today
always great to talk to you good luck
this uh upcoming season hey thanks Dan I
appreciate it say hi to all the boys for
me and I'm gonna be up there in the New
York area a little bit more this fall so
hopefully I can stop in the studio well
we like that thank you JJ all right see
you guys JJ Watt part of CBS Sports
studio in and uh taking part in the
Fredo L's donation to youth Wellness
nonprofit gen youth with the flag
football